yeah i went in there for that like three
times for that
alien i come from the they let you know
with the whole thing
oh yeah they did it was genius i didn't
even think of that i did something else
that was kind of corny and
probably would have ruined the movie
you're very good at voice i remember
your impressions
if like vividly really still
have you updated them with any new
people or is it still cause when they
die you're well i remember
uh i remember keanu when we were working
with piano
i just remember that's when i started to
develop the kana reeves impression
and i loved him i just remember us
sitting in the room and i we we love him
him adore him and he's the best
but i just remember you had to carry
charlize
or we had to carry charlize into the
bathroom she had cancer and
we're we're sitting there and kissing
let's let's be honest she's a big glass
yeah she's a bag of bones it's very easy
yes it's very easy she's very thin
uh very lightweight uh but we're sitting
there
i thought you remain cause she's so tall
but we're sitting there and then keanu
they say action he comes in he has a
scene just goes
sarah and he does this sarah i know
doctors
and he gets and he hits the wall
he's like past like are you okay can i
you need it
you need another you need to admit
minute or so he's like no no i've got
this
action sarah
i know doctors
and he kind of hits the wall again and
then he goes no i got this
can are you sure yeah action
sarah i know doctors
yeah i think that was it and you i
remember all of us looking at you like
what what it was just a funny moment
was a phenomenon